welcome to this video yet another one of
the endgame basics and theory serious
and we are going to look at the first
look end games and how in the serious
Rukh end games are really really
important because they simply come up so
often for some reason shook end games
are the most frequent end games that
arise probably because the looks are at
the edge of the boat and probably there
are the last pieces that come into play
and therefore in the most cases also the
last pieces that getting exchanged yeah
this will be the first video of many
videos on Luke and games and we even
have to cover lots of ground with this
type of position like rook and pawn
against rook this looks very very simple
I mean this position that we have in
front of God is simple because it's the
the simplest of them all in a way um
when you talk about this term when came
but rook and pawn against rook can be
very very tricky and there are so many
positions that can come up it's really
well worth studying because so many
points are lost and then gained and
gained by a good plane or by lost by
worst player but that plane in those end
games it's absolutely countless really
yeah we start with the most basic
position this is called the Philidor
defense of Philidor position again a
free dog position if you have looked at
if you have watched the video on Queenie
against rook there's also Philidor
position Philidor really did
groundbreaking work almost 250 years ago
yeah black to play and draw it's a very
famous way to draw against against them
this this setup
what black needs to do here to secure
the draw is the move rook b6 sometimes
this defense and it's commonly known as
Philidor but just philidor's position
but sometimes also called the six ranked
defense it is characterized by this
barrier that the black rook is setting
up the white king cannot cross the six
rank this is the important thing and
cannot support his pawn and rook two
also with the King on f6 for example you
would threaten checkmate with the rook
so this kind of thing is absolutely
necessary to push the pawn through at
the end the look on the six rank is the
ideal piece to make sure that the king
is not advancing right now it's
absolutely unable to make any progress
it is some useful to know that rook b6
is not the only way to draw there are
other ways to draw for example rook b1
is also possible but it's absolutely
essential to know this drawing method on
the six rank because it is coming up so
often and it is absolutely safe and easy
to play there is very little that can
happen once you have set up this
defensive formation white really only
has one try he needs to push the pawn in
this case the F pawn at some point and
this is very important here it's the F
pawn it is absolutely unimportant what
pawn it is the defensive mechanism works
with all pawns it can be the F pawn the
Jeep on the upon it's absolutely not
important it's also a setup that you can
can use on the fifth rank or fourth rank
if the whole situation is just just
shifted one rank south if you want so
pawn on f4
King on g4 you play would be fine it's
not that important when the pawn is far
back but it's nevertheless a good good
setup so white probably will play f6 now
everything else is not leading to to
anything um you cannot push the King
what you can try to do is some go for go
for a rook trade this this could be an
idea let's say white rice this he goes
with this then black simply stays with
the King yeah you can just stay on the
eighth-ranked if white offers this rook
trade we can trade because we are just
in time here to prevent white from heat
reaching any of the critical squares so
King g5 and black now just stays we have
the opposition and draw easily there is
absolutely no way here that white can
force a rook trade that is winning for
him yeah it's um it requires very little
accuracy from black iam white will play
f6 if he wants to try something so f6
yeah now we come to the to the point of
of all this black now plays rook to be
one yeah like there was to be one so
that now he's able to give checks from
the back with the pawn now on f6 the
White King has no place to hide from the
checks this is not the case if the pawn
is on f5 so white could play if the pawn
of unify he could cook to f6 for example
after check on g1 this is not possible
now the white pawn does not provide any
shelter anymore so black now will be
able to give checks yeah eternally if
you want why there's no way for that he
can just some check here if you want
check does not lead anywhere can push
the King and now we start to give the
checks and she white has absolute
general wave check out of this this
drawing mechanism the Philidor defense
the six ranked defense is the most
important endgame position probably that
you should know
among route rook end games this is
certainly the case and maybe it's the
case in the whole whole world of end
games because it comes up so often and
very often this is the end of those kind
of rook end games
there are however cases where you are
not able to take this defensive position
and we should look at all of them
alternative metal methods that sometimes
are necessary let's look at the position
of that type but a little different one
now yeah this position is indeed
different and the difference is its wide
tooth yeah what about this position with
right to move this is in fact an loss
King g6
is the winning move and the only move
really that wins why is why is it
winning now the problem is that black
now is simply too late if he now gives
us check check want to play f6 and now
has the made threat Brooke aah like now
has no choice he needs to return you
have to cover to cover the mate and now
white is winning due to this idea look
to h7 threatening group h8 mate yeah and
this is really nothing that black can
can prevent he can play King g8 after
which f7 King as I looka Jade picks up
the rook other defensive choice if we go
back and not give this check other
defensive choice don't make much of a
difference if
black plays rook could be won for
example then we go rougane yet kingi 7-6
check important it's with the temple f6
check King e6 rupee check King anywhere
it does not matter f7 and we promote
let's go back yeah what else is there
for black to try let's say he stays on
the eighth rank then white plays f6 King
g8 and now important for white to win he
needs to give this check first check
yeah if you play rook h7 then rook c6
means that you cannot make much progress
you have not spoiled anything you can
still return here and get to the same
position but ultimately you need to give
this check yeah the point is that this
is check check very elementary or after
King f8 we play rook h7 with the tempo
the tempo is the main threat yeah and
now we again win yeah this we have
already seen or alternatively if King EA
displayed check we just force the rook
trade and promote our pawn so very
little details can be very important
here it looks like the same position but
the right to move is a huge difference
now as we have seen if black is to move
then rook b6
secures the draw
let's now look at a specific case where
this passive defense with the rook on
the back rank is indeed working here the
big difference is that the site where
the extra pawn has the Jeep on the Jeep
on or the b-pawn so the knight pawns I
exceptions with those pawns the
defending site can even draw if he just
stays with the king in front of the pawn
and shuffles on the back rank yeah like
like I'm on the eighth-ranked Ian
there's absolutely no way forward for
for white in this position what we can
try is something like that
let's say rook g7 as the first move yeah
very important is that black now plays
the right move because you can still go
wrong if you play King f8 you
unfortunately still lose the reason is
that after King h7 but the black king
will be pushed away from the jeep on and
we will reach a Lucena position this is
what we are going to look at next and it
will be pretty clear once you see what
what's coming up the black king is
simply pushed away from the pawn black
absolutely must go to h8 and now what is
in a situation where absolutely no
progress to be made you can give this
check if you want just we go back again
a check and again we go back what can
stay on the seventh and yeah but where
is he ever going to make progress on a
rook move we simply move our rook so
this is a very simple defensive setup
that that's useful to know with the G
porn or the b-pawn especially if you
consider some practical situation that
saying
Blitz game and you see okay the opponent
has the BMG pawn you don't need to worry
about anything here as long as you are
in front of the pawn and you can put the
rook on the it's rank you can just
shuffle and shuffle and not to f8 maybe
a lot a g7
but you know you can just shuffle the
only thing that really needs to be kept
in mind that check check here you need
to stay here in front of the pawn and
not allow this kind of thing where you
are pushed away from the pawn and
eventually eventually will get to a
Lucina position where you lose yeah what
is this famous lucena position this is
the second most important position in
the elementary rook endgames right after
the Philidor defense on the six rank
let's now look at the famous position
yeah this is oh this is the classic
Lucena position yeah what exactly is the
characteristics of this position it's
about positions where the attacking side
with the pawn is on the seventh rank
with this pawn and is in front of the
pawn this happens very very frequently
white here has a winning maneuver
winning scheme that happens very very
often and it all starts with this
Chicken Shack here on d1 also note that
it's not very much dependent on the pawn
that we talked about it's the same thing
with the Jeep owned by the way for
example check on d1 black king must go
to c6 that's the toughest this being
very basic so k c6 and now how do we
help
with the rook to promote the pawn the
key move here is them look move rook t4
that's the porn thing about this
position and it is also commonly
referred to building a bridge yeah and
why a bridge yeah we will see we will
see soon enough
the thing is black really does not have
anything better then to play let's say
rook g1 there is no alternative to that
and now white can play King e7 rook
check check King f6f check
he really has nothing else King e6 yeah
note that white is all the time
threatening look here and promote so no
black needs to keep on checking and now
we have King a5g I have one group f4 and
this is the bridge that the some
maneuvers is referring to look at
Forrester the bridge in a way on the F
file that shields the King from the
checks checks from the back and helps to
promote the pawn yeah this is absolutely
super important in the initial position
there is more than one way to win yeah
for example ook h1 is also winning Luke
h1h a g8 but this is less important
really if you know the motive you can
always use it if we just fall for once
imagine this would be on the G file yeah
or one to the side then Luke aged one
obviously is not possible as there's no
Luke I won now this is a very important
and Luke endgame the Lucena position
with the bridge building let's look at a
slightly different position that has a
direct connection with the Lucena
position
now we see that we are close to the
lucena what we need here is we need to
get this advanced King to f8 pawn to f7
however this is not so easy to achieve
with Y to move you can easily play play
a wrong move here that looks totally
normal let's say you play King g6 after
King g6 black plays King is 7 and you
don't really have achieved anything yeah
now you cannot go f6 for obvious reasons
and how are you going to make progress
here
yeah let's say look at like get left Lee
goes to f8 & and will draw this g6 is
really a big mistake how do we get ahead
yeah we need to cover the 8th porn
somehow so that the King can advance if
we play rook a5 in order to prepare this
black is just going him and we're not
really getting anywhere
yeah any King move now for example is
answered by the check we are not
spoiling the win here though
look a 5 is not spoiling the wind but is
it's nothing that really yeah brings you
much much progress with black defense
accurately the only very reliable way
forward here is the Mook move rook f8
yeah it looks a bit counterintuitive
maybe but it's important to remember now
white prepares a King move and then the
advance of the pawn yeah like really
does not have much of the defense here
what is what is the toughest one
probably staying on their foul to keep
this pawn pawn under fire if black
place this for example we get to g7 and
ultimately check to f7 yeah we are very
close to the Lucena position now this
this chance can be tried for example
yeah and now we prepare the march of the
airport it will already promote so let's
let's go back and check if black stays
on their front walk f2 King g7 of course
this was what we had prepared all along
check Group G to check yeah black can
also try King to e7 after which check we
now give the check King e6 and route
ahead yeah we want to push the King away
from the pawn if now King f5 we can just
push the pawn and we will promote black
should go to the D file but okay it's
not it's not something that that will
save him we just have f7 and promote so
that's that's really not not helping
let's look at the check okay now we have
managed what we wanted to do getting the
King to f7 rook F 2 and F 6
everyone rugae it yeah the final step is
to get the King to evade something like
that for example check this will net the
desired result we are now very very
close to the lucena
check and that's it put that on the
board once you check check and we have
built the bridge again so it's not that
easy sometimes to get to this winning
position if we go all the way back
really only look at the age is the
reliable way forward in this endgame
otherwise we either spoil it or we make
it much more difficult than then we
needed to need it to make it okay
let's look at a slightly different
position now cab this looks very similar
to the position that we had before
however there's a substantial difference
this is a draw
the idea rupee 8 which looks very much
like rook F aid of the example before
now can be answered by rook h1 and this
is a difference black now has the
additional option to check on the age
farm this means after king f7 he now has
to move check rook h7 and this is of
utmost importance after this check king
g6 black plays kingly 7 which saves the
day yeah quite a funny motive a
counter-attack and here of course
there's no no way for Y to win at all
yeah this is some like here you just
drop all the way back and here white is
faced with this threat and you get to
get nowhere
let's return a couple of moves
if white after Luke h1 tries to move
rook is septic we go to d8 yeah of
course heading in front of the pawn if
possible this is again pretty simple
drawing position yeah something like
look f2 now you give the check the King
goes away and we have the six ranked
defense the Philidor position again if Y
plays rook f6 we can just stay he has
made no progress whatsoever of course
you cannot take as he takes ff7 wins
okay
now for something slightly different as
usual you need to really look at various
versions of those positions to get to
understand the the small nuances that
that are there okay yeah yeah we have a
position with black to move and defend
this is again a very important position
because here black already is in a bit
of trouble he cannot get to the second
rank to the sorry so the six ranked
defense the Philly dog position
so Kenny is still drawn in fact he can
if he plays accurately the right move
has looked to f1 the reason for that is
that if you imagine white checks then
this is what white will do can do it we
of course have no have only this move
and this shows why the Rope must be on
f1 we must be ready to meet f6 yes so
simply with the capture this means that
the check on a8 has not
given white any benefit here he
basically has to return and then we get
the same position all over again the
only way that white can try to make any
progress here is not the check
but King f6 yeah now very important what
should black skin - he threatened with a
mate as simple as that
and you cannot play let's say something
like that because here we simply check
drift into a lost King opponent game
what black has to do now in his sudha
site if he wants to go to the short side
this side of the pond the short side or
the long side and the solution is that
you go to the short side this is very
important and the reason for that is
that ultimately we need to give checks
with the rook from here from the side
somewhere here and this side needs to be
long enough so that you can give the
checks we will see what I'm talking
about
very quickly note that instead King e8
we lose because after the check King d7
and rook f8 we reached the position that
we had seen before white will now force
the Lucena so King g8 is the solution
yeah how does it continue white gives
the check check and King to h7 no other
move how should white try to progress
here if he goes to e6 we go to g7 again
blocking this idea and white has no way
forward
Ruka fate is the toughest drive and now
we see the defensive idea black now
switches all the way to this side of the
board and prepares checks from this side
rupee eight there's no really nothing
else that white can do and now we can
just drop back and ask right okay what
exactly did you achieve now so loopy
eight does not read white anywhere is
there something else that you can try
you're not really a king move you get
checked leads nowhere if you give the
check I have seven you of course just go
back yeah we gladly take a position on
evade something that is it's very easy
drawn note that this is coming and we
have the classic Philidor defense really
absolutely no way forward after the
right move
okay one so something that white can
still try let me check rook e8 rook f1
group ii v yeah trying to cover it from
the side and we go to g8 I guess yes to
g8 and we still have secured the draw
yeah after rook d7 we go here and it's
again the hailstorm of checks we are
very close to just step in front of the
pawn and this is of course a very easy
draw so this is an important thing to
remember if we go back that in this
position you need to step to the short
side not to the long side
of the porn because you need all this
space for the checks afterwards yeah so
that's why in this situation can go here
and have the checks this is completely
impossible from the other side because
the board is simply ending so we need to
get with the king on the short side the
rook on the long side to give the cheque
very important okay there are many more
positions with just rook and pawn
against rook that need to be studied but
in this video of about 30 minutes you
know I've learned some absolutely key
ideas and motifs how to defend these
kind of positions or how to yeah conduct
the position if you have the pawn like
building the bridge very important
device to to win the to win this rook
endgame in certain positions very
important most important is also the
Philidor defense of the six rank and
also this what we just have looked at to
know that you need to go to the short
side of the pawn to defend it is a good
idea to practice this kind of positions
against a computer especially against
the table base if you have the
opportunity because it will play
absolutely perfectly and with this you
can really make sure that you and get
accustomed to those end games and that
it becomes second nature to play them to
play them correctly I can assure you
that with very little time on the clock
the simplest things can get tricky in
those end games so it's really a good
idea to time and time and again repeat
those drawing mechanisms or those
mechanisms like building the bridge so
that you are able to perform them even
under very limited time some of those
things you might argue I defined
that over the board that's no problem
yeah if you have lots of time maybe but
normally those kind of things arise when
you only have very little time left on
the clock or you are living off the
increment in modern modern day time
controls and then you won't work out
everything over the board it's simply
not possible to do if you have little
time left so familiar life familiarizing
yourself with those motifs and and basic
things it's very rewarding in the long
run yeah I hope you enjoyed this this
basic introduction to King rook and pawn
against the lonely king and rook and
there will be many many more to come
thanks for watching